AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME,
"TERMS OF ENSEARCHMENT."
WHEN YOU SEARCH FOR SOMETHING ON
THE INTERNET, YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO FIND.
SOMETIMES YOU GET A COOL FACT,
LIKE HOW PLUTO IS THE SIZE OF
AUSTRALIA.
SOMETIMES YOU GET A VIDEO OF A
CORGI LIP SYNCING THE "SAVED BY
THE BELL" THEME, AND THEN YOU'RE
IN A BAD MOOD FOR THE REST OF
YOUR LIFE.
COMEDIANS, GET YOUR BUZZER
FINGERS READY.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU A PICTURE
OF SOMETHING WE FOUND ON THE
SKYNET, AND I WANT YOU TO TELL
ME THE SEARCH TERM WE USED TO
FIND IT.
BUT ONLY THE FIRST PERSON TO
BUZZ IN GETS TO ANSWER, AND THE
OTHER TWO CAN GO SUCK IT.
I'M PUTTING 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND BEGIN. THIS FIRST ONE.
>> ANDY. DICK'S HARD DRIVE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
THIS ONE?
NICK.
>> WHITNEY'S PUSSY BEFORE SHE
SHAVED.
( APPLAUSE )
>> CHRIS: POINTS FOR NICK.
NEXT ONE.
>> ( BLEEP ).
WHITNEY.
>> FARMERSONLY.COM.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
BRENDON.
>> WHAT'S SCOTT WEILAND BEEN UP
TO?
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> CHRIS: NEXT ONE.
WHAT ABOUT THIS LLAMA? BRENDON.
>> TOM PETTY TICKETS.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> CHRIS: OH, ( BLEEP ).
POINTS TO BRENDON.
NICK.
>> FETISH STARTER KIT?
>> THAT'S IT.
THAT'S THE END OF "TERMS OF
ENSEARCHMENT."